but hey with playing Crash Bandicoot
which for the record I'm not great at
yep
get hit get why did I die here is this
where I fell in the hole
I think it is no dammit
booga-booga indeed damn it I really
thought I had that but I find this
really addictive because what am I
supposed to do oh that was that was you
tricked me you were there just to hurt
me that's real rude
what am I supposed to meet you hmm
curious no hmm hmm jump over him how
this boy too big maybe I figured a
running start I don't know how to do it
jump on his head how how do I get to his
head he's so quick okay stupid jump yep
I hate him I hate him a lot
this is not easy to learn is the thing
is I don't feel like I'm improving jump
nope
oh boy jump jump are you seeing a boy
you just that was that was so stupid I
had it and then I was just like I'll
just walk towards it and then I felt
oh no oh heck oh heck why would you who
sets these up
oh very stress right now who keeps doing
this to people sup girl Oh Oh terrible
oh so stressful okay we did it okay
someone also else what uses my favorite
so let me talk about that stupid why do
I keep doing this to myself yeah I
really like the like all the lab stuff I
like keep thinking that I'm landed on
them and I'm not and I'm running out of
lines
that's real far away [ __ ] you
oh these don't sink oh oh they do cool
cool
excellent nailed that what do you think
of what we've seen so far
what's horizon fall right that's gonna
be my current question answer while
trying to play this very difficult video
game that I'm very bad at are you
screwed it up alright screwing it up
it's really stupid and hard to explain
but basically just for me to be able to
leave the u.s. oh wow he really ate me
worth it turn to quickly
I feel like I probably have the worst
game of face right now what what I hate
myself
all right you know I thought this would
be a pleasant experience but right now I
hate myself
you making me hate myself oh boy we do
that and then we jump back over here and
then we jump over here and then we jump
on this we're gonna stay on this for a
little bit to make sure we like figure
out the situation then we're gonna jump
over here damn it I am improving just
very she says I can't avoid the TNT you
can I know oh just you could just punch
it Ilana that's fine no no no not you
again not you anyone but you right here
there's a death spike trap behind him I
think I came over right in front of the
shield man this is okay it's just this
that I'm worried about it's just him all
right okay okay okay okay great great
great great great great great
screen no it was right there
a boy this level is hard
oh no I'm super nervous okay okay that's
[ __ ]
I psyched myself out
oh no I don't know I'm too I'm too
nervous why am i why do I feel like this
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you that was [ __ ] that
was goddamn [ __ ] uh oh my god
[ __ ] you monkey all right
didn't expect that but it happened it's
gonna do a little thought and then a big
fight and then we jump on it and jump on
this one and jump on this one punch this
[ __ ] you duh okay what starting at the
Sun again it's fine
how it [ __ ] you right on that except
you're super great I rushed it that's
where that happened that's where we
failed a little man of all places stupid
it's stupid
what thank you
come on okay oh my god please get me out
of here
this seems like an ending oh my god this
is good but why is there a catch why did
you give me all of those yes [ __ ] oh my
god oh my god how long did that